so yeah they're definitely following us
so this could put an
end to our video on photograph very
quickly so
the security apparatus in xinjiang was
pretty intense
you know before i went to xinjiang i was
in my head i was saying things like well
you know it's probably uh exaggerated
somewhat
but it was actually a little bit more
those are two of the cars that have been
following us for at least a couple of
hours now
column and james are reporters for
bloomberg news they've traveled to
xinjiang china
a region at the very heart of the
country's solar ambitions
and what government critics say is the
center of a crackdown on uyghurs
and other minorities
factories like this one churn out vast
quantities of polysilicon
the raw material in billions of solar
panels all over the world
solar panels are modules and nearly all
solar panels are made out of polysilicon
essentially
almost any crystalline silicon module is
likely to have a small amount
or more of xinjiang silicon in it very
few are actually
pure chinese companies dominate the
solar industry
and collectively control at least 60
percent of global capacity at
every step in the supply chain in
xinjiang alone
these four factories dacho new energy
shinta energy
east hope group and gcl poly energy are
expected to produce
nearly half the global polysilicon
supply in total
china is expected to produce over 80
percent of the world's polysilicon
the region attracts this industry mainly
i would say because of electricity
xinjiang has a lot of relatively cheap
coal polysilicon is made using a lot of
energy
so essentially cheap electricity means
cheap polysilicon
fueled by cheap polysilicon solar
capacity is set to grow by about a
quarter this year
2020 saw record installations backed by
almost 150 billion dollars in investment
bringing solar panels to energy farms
and homes around the world
the problem is that this industrial boom
is reliant on china's troubled xinjiang
region
and almost no one outside china knows
what goes on inside the polysilicon
factories
and consumers companies and governments
are growing uneasy about their reliance
on the region
rife with alleged human rights abuses
shinto energy east hope group and gcl
poly energy holdings
have been linked to a state-run
employment programme that according to
some
foreign governments and academics may at
times amount to forced labor
we welcome more foreign nationals to
visit xinjiang and to see you with their
own eyes the achievements made there
we also call our media outlets that are
committed to objective and unbiased
reporting
as well as professional ethics to tell
the true story
through their paper pen camera and a
microphone
which will expose the rumors and the
lies about xinjiang
we visited uh four of the polysilicon
plants over a period
of two to three days
[Music]
i'm getting the same
ring tone seems to be anyway
so we're just leaving the factory and we
have been in touch with them many times
uh to try to set up an interview uh the
company has
uh repeatedly said no or are delayed
on our requests and most recently said
that uh
the topic was very sensitive so we came
here today to see for ourselves and try
to
see if that would make a difference but
the end result was that we
were not able to conduct an interview
we're told on the one hand come visit
you know we want
journalists to come but the reality is
just so starkly different
the main place that we we encountered
workers was at shinta
we just happened on the scene just
around the time when they were changing
shift
and a small group two or three of those
people stopped
to to listen to what i had to say uh
at which point they they went almost on
script and said
oh we cannot speak to uh reporters you
have to speak to the company we're not
allowed to speak on behalf of the
company
they obviously had been well trained by
the company
to respond to this situation should
somebody from the outside whether it be
a journalist or
a diplomat ask them questions about
what's what's going on
in the factory we in the end didn't make
it
into any of the polysilicon factories to
see the facilities inside
and we didn't get to meet any of the
executives and only spotted a few
workers
the strictly enforced secrecy in
xinjiang has made the search for answers
about
links between china's labour programme
and its solar industry
a problem for outside researchers who it
turns out
can find telling details just by combing
through public records
so this document is from the tbea
website
tbea is the parent company of shinto
energy what it says is something that's
so unprecedented i've never seen this
the company
not only accepts labor transfers of
of weaker workers from the government
the company actually has
a poverty alleviation cadre a card was a
government official
poverty alleviation government officials
in xinjiang do it says literally
in the text the cadre enters households
talks face-to-face with the poor spreads
the party's policies
and then it says literally prescribes
the right
medicine meaning implements targeted
poverty alleviation according to the
actual situation of the household and as
a result
the thinking of the villagers has been
greatly changed
this is adrian zenz a researcher who
recently uncovered unreported documents
because of his work zen's has been a
focus of china's wrath
so this the gcl energy company says
as of the end of 2019 the company
accepted 121
ethnic minority workers from poor
regions in southern china
so what you're seeing here is something
that's very common you basically have a
government farewell ceremony for trained
ethnic minority laborers you see them
lining up and then they go off to their
respective companies you see there's a
high
focus on uniformity but the most
important always is the text
so you have the transfer of surplus
laborers and then you have
the whole context you know and it's a
center of ceremony to these companies
one of the companies named here is is
the one that produces polysilicon
east hope
says their initiatives train workers and
send them to factories as part of an
effort to help
poor ethnic minorities find better
employment
means
the issue here critics say is that
there's a lack of
choice and that when ethic minorities
including the uyghurs are approached
and encouraged to participate in such
poverty alleviation programs
they're not really left with much room
to say no attempting to say no
to a forced labor program for example
might land someone right back in a camp
or in some other kind of carceral
setting
when consumers general public hear about
what's happening to the uyghurs the
general reaction may have been
oh that's another human rights problem
or it's china
it's too remote or it's another muslim
group maybe causing trouble
but this is not about the uyghurs
anymore this is about us
consumers or free people the market for
solar power has surged as governments
and companies around the world
race to stop global warming that means
millions of home owners buying solar
panels everywhere
face an awful trade-off embrace the
green future
and you're possibly purchasing the
products of forced labor
there's little evidence that forced
labor is involved in polysilicon
manufacturing
that said any company that's active in
shenzhen
is cooperating with the regime there so
it's impossible to have a clear
conscience in march
the us the european union and canada put
new sanctions on china
over alleged human rights abuses the u.s
has already banned imports of cotton
and tomatoes the substance needed for
solar panels
could be next
it's really part of a broader tension
between
china and the west makes me wonder like
when
or if ever the two sides are going to
see
common ground on this issue because in
my mind it just seems to be
we're growing further and further apart
[Music]